I think we all have a duty within you
get to actually represent and speak for
the four million people who voted for us
fifty thousand party members and we've
been working very very hard Patrick's
played a part in there to
professionalize our party and I think
personal attacks on anybody be the
leader or anybody else are
unprofessional and undignified and don't
do us any favors whatsoever do you think
his advisers took the party in the wrong
direction do you think they pushed him
to become more angry and aggressive to
the detriment of the party absolutely
not our campaign was actually very
successful of course it was very very
disappointing that Nigel wasn't
successful on the night and the other
MPs who work very very hard other
candidates weren't successful but our
campaign overall was very successful
we've got 3.9 million votes we got more
votes than the liberal democrats in the
SMP combined and indeed we won hundreds
of council seats across the country
let's not forget that actually we won
control of thanet council where Nigel
standing where I was standing we won
seven council seats that night so was
actually a good campaign it's common
knowledge in Westminster circles that
the two advisors that he's referring to
r-rahim kasam and Matt Richardson
Patrick O'Flynn wouldn't name them in
the interview i did with him just now
you would back them then would you to
stay on in their job as advisors the
nigel farage 100% they did a great job
and look it wasn't just then there was a
great big team of people working on the
campaign the campaign was thought out
and well-planned many many months in
advance it was a key seed strategy that
was applied very carefully and indeed it
was a deliberate call vote strategy and
actually it did cut through and that's
why we got such support on the night in
fact two weeks before the very effective
campaign of scaring people into the
prospect of an SMP labour coalition was
clearly effective in people across the
country on the doorstep said we agree
with all of you kids policies we agree
with what you are saying we will vote
for you locally but we're now scared
about the SNP labour and indeed it
wasn't just you Kip that was affected by
that squeeze other parties
as well a quick point you're saying it
was a very successful campaign but Nigel
Farage didn't win his seat and you ended
up with one MP of course and that was
disappointing and that was a direct
result of the SMP squeeze factor our
campaign in terms of getting our
messages across was very effective and
we could report our votes and we've got
lots and lots of councillors elected
going forward we've got 120 second
places we've got four point nine million
the 3.9 million votes more than yes MP
and Lib Dems combined and we have now a
great platform to positively move
forward other things people have said
actually is that our campaign wasn't
positive our campaign slogan was
believed in Britain how can you can't
get any more positive than that